let's think a little bit about some of
the properties of alcohol so the general
formula for an alcohol we saw is some
type of group or chain of carbons bonded
to an oxygen bonded to a hydrogen and of
course the oxygen will have two lone
pairs just like that let's compare this
to water so water just looks like this
you know hydrogen bonded to an oxygen
bonded to another hydrogen with two lone
pairs now in the case of water the
oxygen is much more electronegative than
the hydrogen so it hogs the electrons
towards it so you have a partial you
have a partial negative charge at the
oxygen end and then you have partial
positive charges you have partial
positive charges at the hydrogen ends
and that's what Oh that's what allows
oxygen to chi or sorry that's what
allows water to kind of bond to itself
or to kind of have not a ridiculously
low boiling point so let me show this so
let me copy and paste this and we've
seen all this before in regular
chemistry so copy and paste so let me
draw some more water molecules here and
let me draw another water molecule here
so you see water because the oxygen end
has a partial negative charge and the
hydrogen ends have partial positive
charges the oxygen of one water molecule
will be attracted to the hydrogen of
another water molecule and we've seen
this before this we call hydrogen
bonding so that right there is hydrogen
bonding hydrogen bonding the exact same
thing can happen with alcohols although
alcohols really only have the partial
positive charge on the hydrogen we don't
know exactly what's going on here we
have probably have carbons bonded to the
oxygen and with the carbons they're not
as they're reasonably electronegative
they're not going to have their
electrons hogged as much as a hydrogen
would so in the case of an alcohol
actually let me draw instead of having
this R 4 radical there let me make it a
little bit more concrete let me draw an
actual alcohol so an actual alcohol
maybe we have methanol maybe we have
methanol it would look like that it has
a hydrogen right over here ox
is much more electable electronegative
than the hydrogen so you have a partial
negative charge there and then you have
a partial positive charge there so it -
because of these hydrogen bonds it will
have a reasonable boiling we won't just
turn immediately into the gaseous state
it would actually try to bond to each
other let me copy and paste that so it
can also form the hydrogen bonds
although they won't be quite as strong
as what you see in water and that's why
something like methanol actually has a
lower boiling point than water it's easy
to make it boil it's easier to make
these bonds break apart because you
don't have as much of the hydrogen
bonding so this is an example of
hydrogen bonding with methanol now
because methanol can have hydrogen bond
hydrogen bonding and it has this slight
polarity to it and water obviously has
hydrogen bonding methanol is actually
miscible in water and all that means is
that it's soluble in water in any
proportion no matter how much methanol
or how much water you have it is soluble
so if I were to draw some methanol
molecules you may be actually maybe this
is the water right here so if you drop a
methanol molecule right there this would
have that would have a hydrogen bond
right over there or draw another
methanol molecule maybe right over here
you would have another hydrogen bond
right over there and that's what allows
methanol to be soluble in water now as
this chain grows or if you have alcohols
with longer radical chains then they
become less and less soluble in water
but their boiling points actually do go
up and let's think about why that is so
if I have something like let me do
butanol so butanol is going to have 4
carbons so it's going to be a ch3 ch3
let me just draw it like a ch3 see ch2
ch2 CH let me do it like this H to see
then that carbon that last carbon right
there is going to be bonded to the
oxygen it's going to be bonded to an
oxygen which is
bonded to a hydrogen now when you have a
situation like this the oxygen will have
a partial negative charge the hydrogen
will still have a partial positive
charge just like we saw up here with
both the water and the methanol but now
you have this big thing here that has no
polarity so this part of the alcohol is
not going to be soluble in water it's
going to make it harder for this part to
be soluble over here so this right here
is less soluble this is less soluble it
still be a little bit soluble so if you
have some oxygen here you will still
have a little bit of the hydrogen
bonding you still will have a little bit
of the hydrogen bonding going on but
this part is kind of you can imagine
it's almost you know it doesn't want to
dissolve with the water it is non-polar
and so this is you could actually for
example butanol in particular it
actually is soluble in water but not in
any proportion so methanol is miscible
let me write this and this is a new word
I don't think I've ever used it before
in the context of the organic chemistry
videos so the methanol is let me write
that in a brighter color since it's a
new word methanol is miscible miscible
which just means soluble in any
proportion soluble soluble in any
proportion so I don't care what what
percent is is is methanol what
percentage water they will the methanol
will dissolve into the water in any
proportion if you look at butanol it is
soluble but not in any proportion if you
had a ton of butanol some of it would
not dissolve in the water so this is
soluble so the butanol right here is
soluble soluble but not not miscible not
miscible in water if you have too much
of the butanol all of a sudden some of
it will not actually be able to be
dissolved and if this chain if this was
a deccan all or something with a really
long carbon chain then of course it's
going to be very non soluble I mean you
might be able to get a couple of
molecules in the water but most of them
will not dissolve now the other reason I
you know I hinted look you know the
reason why the alcohols have
well you know not to lovo boiling point
is that they're able to do this hydrogen
bonding but you would say well look you
know these longer carbon chains these
are going to have less of the hydrogen
bonding going on maybe these would have
lower boiling points but actually the
longer the chain gets these actually
have higher boiling points and that's
because these chains can interact with
each other so the longer the chain so
longer longer are or the longer our
chain I guess I could say we could say
the higher the boiling point in an
alcohol higher boiling point it's harder
you have to put more heat into the
system or the temperature has to be
higher for the things to be rigged apart
and that's because this is one Deccan
all molecule here another Deccan all
molecule might look like this maybe
might look like this if an oxygen and a
hydrogen and then you have your carbons
so you have your CH your CH 2 CH 2 H 3 C
so you have this other butanol here and
what the interaction between these two
chains are dependent you know these
these are the Vander Waal forces so you
know even though they have no products
so these guys are going to have some
polar interactions they're going to have
the hydrogen bonding we've seen that
multiple times already but these long
chains they're going to have the London
dispersion forces which are a subset of
Vander Waal forces where even though
they're neutral every now and then one
of these might become slightly negative
on one side so you might have a very
temporary you might have a temporary
partial negative charge and that's just
because of the randomness of how
electrons move on this side of the
molecule all of a sudden you might have
more electrons over there so you have a
partial negative charge and and because
of that you're going to have the
electrons over here get what they're not
going to want to be there so you're
going to have a partial positive charge
then you can have a very temporary
interaction that's a very weak force
much weaker than hydrogen bonds but as
these chains get longer and longer is is
they possibly even get intertwined with
each other and get close to each other
these London dispersion forces or Vander
Waal forces are going to keep
propagating so all of a sudden maybe
these guys are going to be attracted to
each other and that's going to disappear
then these guys are going to be
attracted to each other and then that's
going to disappear and then these guys
are going to be attracted to each other
and then that's going to disappear and
so you can imagine the longer the chain
the
more of these type of interactions
you're going to have the more attracted
they're going to be to each other and
it's going to be harder to break them
apart higher boiling point so those are
just kind of the two big takeaways on
the properties of alcohols they are the
especially smaller chained alcohols are
soluble in water the very small ones are
completely miscible and the longer the
chain you have the harder is to dissolve
in water but also the higher the boiling
point the heart the harder it is to
break them apart because you have these
London dispersion forces